presidents Trump smartly asked for 25
billion dollars to build the border wall
but Congress gave him one point six
billion dollars in some of it for
fencing Border Patrol agents tell us
that they are livid over that but the
mainstream media is saying just the
opposite a New York Times headline
yesterday declared what border agents
say they want it's not a wall the Times
cited a survey put out by Senate
Democrats that claimed border agents
really just want more technology but the
Department of Homeland Security says
Democrats got it all wrong
let's get to the bottom of this with the
president of the National Border Patrol
Council
Brandon Judd and the law and Laredo
Texas representative of that council
Border Patrol agent Hector Garza
gentlemen great to see both of you
Brandon let's start with you on this I
saw this and I've known you guys for so
long I've noticed I've been friends with
so many in the border patrol since 1996
when I first started in the media when I
saw this I thought this doesn't even
pass you know the straight faith test in
any way shape or form your reaction and
that Democratic staff report is nothing
more than garbage it makes me sick
knowing that the taxpayers funded a
report that is nothing more than a
partisan hit piece on a president whom
they hate and want to see fail we can't
allow the Democrats to lie to the
American public senator Johnson needs to
call for a hearing on this issue it
needs to be billed before the Senate
Ethics Committee and and we've got to
investigate this and get to the bottom
because I can tell you I I just finished
my shift a couple hour hours ago
patrolling the border I speak with
hundreds of agents on a daily basis and
all of those agents are telling me we
need walls and strategic locations and
we're gonna prove that we need those
walls Hector here's what the Democratic
study says okay we have a full screen
we'll put up border agents and sector
chiefs rarely requested a wall only one
urgent and compelling request mentioned
either a wall or fencing most commonly
identified vulnerabilities called for
tech personnel in your experience
Tector with everything you guys are up
against does that ring true
not at all Laura I work in the Laredo
sector and then in the Loretto sector we
do not have a single mile of border wall
or physical barrier and the Laredo
sector is next to the Rio Grande Valley
sector which is the busiest sector in
the nation for drug crossings and for
people that are coming across illegally
so now we've called for a wall in the
Laredo sector because just in the Laredo
sector we have the across the board we
have the dangerous drug cartel known as
Los Zetas there are very dangerous they
bring a lot of drugs into our country
and they also smoke a lot of people into
the United States
we definitely a physical barrier that's
gonna save American lives and and you
guys you might have heard the segment we
just did on this budget that just passed
there are no there's no money for more
detention beds there's no money for that
big beautiful concrete wall that we had
heard about for so long the president
wanted 1.6 billion just for the wall
there's like 640 million for a variety
of things and maybe 33 miles or
different different reports think it's
33 miles for reinforced double fencing
and some levee walls that are already
there
but this is no new construction so
Brandon like I'm hearing you guys you
guys are on the from the front line the
cartels are coming we got the human
trafficking people just trying to cross
because they want to work here others we
don't know what their motives are and
we're like well we're gonna have some
set of sensors and we'll have some roads
and maybe we'll have some more detention
facilities now the Republicans are
shooting themselves in the foot the
president ran on a campaign of domestic
policies that were going to secure the
American interest which and one of those
was the border the Republicans aren't
doing what the the constituency wants
them to do and if they don't jump on
board and if they don't get behind this
president if they don't secure the
border they stand to lose huge in the
midterms we got to I agree the
Republicans get behind this president
we've got to get rid of the swamp and
that includes the swamp within our own
agency if we're if we're gonna expect to
hold the house in the Senate in 2018
Hector this is what the president said
today again
he didn't like the fact that he had to
sign this but he did go ahead and sign
it let's listen we're going to be
starting work literally on Monday on not
only some new wall not enough but we're
working on that very quickly but also
fixing existing walls and existing
acceptable fences there are some areas
that you have to see through you have to
be able to see through the other side
daughter to see what's coming and in
many cases it's not a pretty picture oh
my god okay number one Hector just
explained the part that we need to have
see-through wall I mean I understand you
do need to see kind of you know what's
happening on the other side but I don't
think there's gonna be any physical wall
being built because there's no money for
the wall it's all repairing the fencing
that exists and the levee walls that are
already there and some of them crumbling
but can you you can shed any light on
that for me because I've got to frankly
buy a vowel I don't really understand it
well it's just very unfortunate that we
can't get a border wall a much neater
wall that we needed to so that we can do
our job and that was gonna be save
American lives and it's just very
fortunate that that some of these
representatives are actually playing
games with with our jobs and with our
security we need to stop playing
politics and we need to sois it's no
secret
our Border Patrol agents have actually
reached out to president truck through
throughout the National Border Patrol
Council and they've told that we want to
walk president Chopp has done the same
thing he's spoken to our agents directly
and the agents have told him president
Trump we need a war to secure the border
and that's what we need so that we could
do our job and this or that we could
save those American lives and stop those
drugs from coming across Brandon I have
to read for you you're gonna love this
this is Senator Claire McCaskill I know
you guys are texting buddy buddies she
said this okay she's on the Homeland
Security Committee this report
reinforces what I've heard from
frontline border agents and CPB leaders
alike that the top priorities for
addressing vulnerabilities along our
border are additional personnel and
better technology we can't let politics
get in the way of our efforts to
strengthen border security and protect
our country
she said that also Paul Ryan has been
very chipper about the idea of all this
sensor
and the drones and the and they on the
other accoutrements to enforce the
border but what I understand from Israel
and when I understand from you and all
the years I've known you
without that barrier it makes your life
more difficult at every turn and Hector
I assume you would agree but Brandon you
first Laura we've played that game we've
thrown all kinds of technology at drones
at censors it's interesting that the
Democratic reports quotes
former Deputy Commissioner David Aguilar
David Aguilar now sits on the on the
board of drone aviation industry
obviously he doesn't want a wall because
if he gets a wall he's not gonna be
selling drones
if people aren't crossing the border
illegally there's no need to buy drones
we've already done that we don't need to
do it again we need to build the
physical barriers that are necessary
yeah you think about a Hector and
Brandon you got the sensor companies you
got the drone companies everybody's
looking for a piece of the pie right
there all the money that's gonna be
invested but if it's just the wall and
the extra personnel and so forth it's a
lot simpler it's a lot simpler guys god
bless you for the work you do keep it up
and the American people and I know so
many of our viewers at Fox and and on
radio and beyond they're just with you
100% so keep up the great work